ونبقى مع نجم العالمي الجديد يلي بتشاركه
بطوله الخبر الطفله اللي اهداها الدون
خلال حفل تقديمي في الملعب المرسول بارك
كره قدم من توقيعه وكان اختارها من بين
الاف الحضور ونحن في تفاعلكم فردنا بلقاء
خاص مع الطفله ننصحكم تتابعوه لانه في
اخبار جميله
[موسيقى]
في ملعب مرسول مبارك لكن هذه الكره كانت
لافته الذهب كريستيانو رونالدو
وانتقع طفله صغيره من بين الاف الاشخاص
الذين تواجد في الملعب هذه الكره هي
لعاليه لها عشان بس ما تزعل علينا وعليها
هي الطفله الوحيده التي همم او الشخص
الوحيد حتى في الملعب الذي ذهب اليه
كريستيانو واعطاه الكره اليوم
انت ناديتي كريستيانو ولا كريستيانو هو
الي جاك
لما جاك انتي عارفه انه حيعطيك الكره
الناس اللي وراني ولا جنبي ولا
من كريستيانو
اختك ما ترجعها لكريستيانو ايش اللي صار
بيلعب معها
وانا ما كنت فيه بابا اللي قال لها ما
ترجعها ايه ايه فانا كنت في الجزء يعني
شويه الجهه الثانيه بعيد مره
وجيت وهي معها الكوره كلها حد
يتجمع عليها يبغى الكوره يبغى يصور
لمن اخذتيها كيف الناس
كلهم يناظرهم في الكوره اللي معك
ايه
عشان كده حسين الكره الي معك مهمه
[موسيقى]
عشان كده بتبيعنها لي صح
بعد محاولاتي وعبد الله لشراء الكره لانها
بعت بالفشل الان مع ابو عبد الله ابو عبد
الله نرحب فيك
يعني زين اني انا قدرت اني اخذ الكره
انا موافق بس عاد قويتهم
جدا جدا جدا
[موسيقى]